The list of people who continue to insist
that Robert Mueller's report can be accurately
summarized as no collusion, no obstruction
is getting smaller and smaller even though
Trump's hardcore base still believes it.
And even Fox News host Bret Baier, who just
a few weeks ago tried to tag team Bernie Sanders
during that Fox News town hall along with
the other moderator, Martha Maccallum.
Even that Bret Baier now admits when Mueller
spoke yesterday, he didn't say no collusion,
no obstruction.
Now this is small.
It's a small win, but every time somebody
on the right wing Echo Chambers, uh, a list
of characters tells an even uncontroversial
truth about the Mueller probe, it's a good
thing.
It's another attempt to pierce that echo chamber
in which a lot of these right wingers are
living.
Bret Baier.
Yesterday, right after Robert Mueller gave
his statement during which he said, if we
could have cleared Trump, we would have cleared
Trump, but we didn't.
Bret Baier appeared on Fox News to provide
analysis as they call it a, and he said, this
is much more than no collusion, no obstruction.
Check it out.
Bret Baier standing by anchor, a special report.
Brett, your takeaway from all of that, Robert
Mueller resigning and returning to private
life and he said a lot there.
He did.
He also said he is not planning on testifying
and bill's right there could be a subpoena
that compels him to, but uh, he's making the
choice not to.
I was struck by the tone and tenor of those
remarks, uh, as he laid out his, his case
wrapping up this report, this was not, as
the president says time and time again, no
collusion, no obstruction.
It was much more nuanced than that.
He said specifically they couldn't find evidence
sufficient to move forward with a crime on
the issue of conspiracy, uh, on the collusion
part of the investigation of the Trump campaign,
he said specifically if they had found, uh,
that the president did not commit a crime
on obstruction, they would have said that
and then went into specific details.
So you might react to this by saying, who
cares what Fox News clown, Bret Baier says,
well, the reason we care is because the Fox
News crowd is significantly clueless about
this reality.
It matters that Bret Baier says, this is not
no collusion, no obstruction, because a lot
of the core Fox News audience has been living
under the belief of no collusion, no obstruction.
Ever since the bar letter came out and Donald
Trump went on a nationwide, no collusion,
no obstruction victory tour, they are watching
Fox News not because it informs them but because
it makes them feel good because it sort of
confirms their preconceived notions that confirms
what they want to be true, which makes them
feel good and it actually goes even further
because for some people Fox News confirms
their biases.
For other people, people who are even less
informed, Fox News is actually setting the
biases which works and it even works on Trump.
Fox News sometimes sets Trump's position and
point of view on different issues and that's
why it matters that Bret Baier says this,
and what you have to understand about Fox
is that it is a business that makes money
from right wing news and commentary.
If Donald Trump ultimately turns on Fox News
or Fox News believes that it's just no longer
profitable to be the Trump channel, they'll
stop.
They'll still be right wing, but they can
separate from Trump at any time.
There are many shades of right wing propaganda.
There can be conservative propaganda.
There's statist authoritarian propaganda,
which is sort of de facto right wing.
There's trumpy and propaganda.
Of course, there's anti Democratic Party propaganda.
Not all right wing propaganda assumes this
sort of endless unwavering support of Donald
Trump.
I don't actually expect the change anytime
soon, but the point is, Fox News is propaganda
is carefully calculated for profit and what's
profitable for them could change over time,
and if it does, they will abandon Donald Trump.
They won't abandon the right wing, but they
will abandon Donald Trump.